[موسيقى]
مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض نبداها بالعناوين
الامريكي في اليمن يدعوان لتجنب التصعيد
واعاده تثبيت الهدنه
اعضاء في مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي في تصريحات
للعربيه يعربون عن استيائهم من قمه ايران
للمحتجين
احصائيات سعوديه تكشف ارتفاع ايجارات
الشقق بنسبه تقترب من 16 في المئه الشهر
الماضي
السعوديه تطلق استراتيجيات لتنميه القدرات
الثقافيه لربط مخرجات التعليم باحتياجات
سوق العمل
مدينه جده تستعد لاحتضان اول بنال للفنون
الاسلاميه في العالم تحت شعار اول بيت
والعربيه تتجول في مسقط وترافق شابا
عمانيا يطمح لتوثيق التراث الغذائي
والماكولات العمانيه
اكدت بعثه الاتحاد الاوروبي في اليمن انه
سفراء الاتحاد والسفير الامريكي يؤكدونا
الحاجه الى تجنب التصعيد وضبط النفس ما
اعاده تثبيته لفتره طويله وموسعه ضمن
الجهود الدوليه والامميه لاخلال السلام في
اليمن
وتعمل على اضافه شروط جديده
الايران والاحتجاجات المستمره والانتهاكات
التي يمارسها النظام بحق المتظاهرين حيث
كده مدير الطوارئ في مستشفى سيناء في
طهران الدكتور حسين كرمان بور سوء حاله
المتظاهرين المصابين الذين راجعوا
المستشفى وقال الدكتور كرمان لصحيفه اهم
مهام بان اكثر المتظاهرين اصيبوا في العين
والرئه والمناطق الحساسه في الجسم واضاف
بان السلطات الطلبه من امن المستشفيات
الاعلان عن اسماء المصابين في الاحتجاجات
مما ادى الى امتناع العديد من المصابين من
المراجعه المستشفيات وقال الطبيب ان بعض
المراكز الطبيه الخاصه تقدم العلاج
للمصابين بالتخفيضات تتراوحو بين 50 و
100% كما اكد بانه تم علاجه بعض الاشخاص
في المنزل ان هناك اطباء وممرضات وممرضين
يذهبون الى المنازل الى علاج الجرح
القمر في ايران يبدو انه لا يطال فقط عموم
الشعب بينما يصل الى الدائره القريبه من
خامنه حيث كشف محمود مراد خالي ابن شقيقه
علي الخامنئي للعربيه بان والده تم قتله
بسبب معارضته النظام الايراني
ابن ابنه مصطفى كان صديقه في يوم من
الايام همم
ولكن اخواني قبل وفاهته همم طالب همم
العديد من الامور وطلب بالعديد من الاشياء
محمود مراد خاني قال ان النظام الايرانيه
سيسقط عند وفاه خامنه متهم النظام في
تصريحاته للعربيه بمحاولته كبح كل تحركات
العائله ومنع والدته من مغادره المنزل
وقد عرب مجموعه من اعضاء مجلس الشيوخ
الامريكي في تصريحات للعربيه اعربوا عن
استيائهم من قمع النظام الايراني
للاحتجاجات الشعبيه التي تشهدها مختلف
المدن الايرانيه
ابو عيسى
بفتح النار على الشعب كما اكد بان الموقف
الاوروبيه موحد ازاء ايراني
اينما تفعله الحكومه الايرانيه غير مقبول
وليس له مبرر من يطلق النار على شعبه
الحكومه الايرانيه تفعل ذلك
من لندن الدكتور علي نور زاد رئيس مركز
الدراسات العربيه لرانيا دكتور علي اهلا
وسهلا بك معي في نشره الرابعه دنيا
في تصريحات ابن شقيقه علي الخامنئي
للعربيه وتحدث
وقال بان هناك انشقاقات داخل عائله خامني
هل ذلك صحيح وباي حجم وهل له اي تاثير على
مسار الاحتجاجات فيه
صديقي
هذا الموقف ليس جديده
ومن يقيمون ببلجيكا وقائد اسباب
خروجه من ايران السقوط التي مرست عليهم
[موسيقى]
100%
ابتعد عن النظام
وهو لا يدور اخوه لا يزوره
من قريب وبعيده تركه الرجل والرجل لا يعيش
فد ازل الدوليه
وايضا اصدقائه القدماء
يعني وانت قريب منه كما ذكر الدكتور في
مساله حجم حالات الانشقاق داخل عائله
خميني والى اي مدى تنش- يشعر منه
او النظام بخطوره هذا الامر اليوم مع
تصاعد الاحتجاجات
بلال لما كان يحضن الشباب بلا اي جريمه
بلا اي زينبري
والان بلغ عدد همم
قتله في شوارع اكثر من 480 شخص في اربعه
الاف في سجون هل ممكن ان نتصبر اي حكومه
اخرى في العالم لو ارتكب هذا الجرائم هل
كان همم ردود ال- الدول الغربيه والدول
الكبرى بهذا يعني فقدنا نفسيه بلا اتخاذ
قرارات مهمه بما في هذه السفراء بما فيها
صاحب الايراني كما فعلوا بعد الاختيارات
السياسيه
يعني خامني بنفسه
قرب مسيره مشيره لن يكون افضل من قذافي او
صدام بلا تدخل خارجي نحن لا نلتزم تدخل
الخارجيا بل فقد موقفا مشرفه
ابناءنا في الشوارع يقتلون ليلا ونهارا في
سجون النظام الان هم بسداد اعدام احد
ابطال كره القدم
الامر الذي لا يتحقق حتى الان هو مرتبط
بموت خامنه هل يمكن القول بذلك كما جاء في
تصريحات مراد خاني الى العربيه
بالتاكيد وفاه سوف يكون عامل مهم ولكن حتى
بدون وفاته هباب في راي الشعب الايراني
ميت رجل فقط
[موسيقى]
خذ خذ جدا نحو انتصار شكرا جزيلا الدكتور
رئيس مركز الدراسات العربيه الايرانيه
حقوق الانسان السعوديه
تخيل ان تمتلك ارضا فريده تتلالا وسط
منطقه سياحيه مفعمه بالاصاله والحداثه على
طريق المدينه المنوره وطريق الملك عبد
الله الفريده بها تعلو سحابه الاستثمار
ترجمه في بلدنا فيها شيء ميزها يا سيدي
على لمه اهل الحجاز لقمه منتو على سفرتهم
ولا الحنين تحت غيوم الجنوب وسط جبالها
والله على صحن جديد اجمعنا في نجد الاحباب
وما تدري تمدح اللمه ولا المجبوس ما نسمه
هواء على بحر الشرقيه
وبهارات ثري دي يا بعد حيي ماخذه من ريح
الهبوب الشماليه ولبن المراعي طعام المميز
حاضر معنا فيك الجمعه الحلوه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الملايين سموا ومرحله التصوير لمنال على
اعلى نسب تسميات بدات الان صوت عبر تطبيق
فئه السينما المسلسلات الموسيقى الرياضه
ومواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
التسجيل عبر التطبيق لتكون احد الفائزين
ال 10 بفرصه الفوز لتذكارتين لحضور هذا
الحدث الضخم مع ضيف من اختياره لتعيش ليله
فوق الخيال وتشاهد لحظه تكريم نجومكم
المفضلين
نتائج التصويت تعلن خلال حفل توزيع جوائز
صناع التركي
من يناير لعام 2023 مباشره من الرياض
فسارع بالتصويت الان لان صوتك انت هو
الحاسب
تطبيق جوي اورد متوفر على اب ستور وجوجل
بلاي
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد
عن ارتفاع عن في التضخم خلال شهر نوفمبر
الماضي بالمقارنه مع نفس الشهر من العام
الماضي تفاصيل مع العنود
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا هيه الاحساس السعوديه
كشفت في بياناتها الرسميه اليوم ان نسبه
التضخم في البلاد بلغت نحو ثلاثه بالمئه
خلال شهر نوفمبر الماضي وارجعت السبب في
هذا ارتفاع الى زياده اسعار السكن والمياه
والكهرباء والغاز التي ارتفعت بنسبه تقترب
من خمسه في المئه لكن مشاهدينا ما الذي
تسبب في ارتفاع مؤشرات اسعار السكن حيث
الاحصاء قالت ان السبب او وراء هذا ارتفاع
هو زياده اسعار ايجارات الشقق التي ارتفعت
بنسبه كبيره خلال العام واحد بلغت نحو 16%
بنهايه نوفمبر ايضا من ضمن اسباب ارتفاع
تضخم زياده اسعار الغذاء والمشروبات بنسبه
تجاوزت ثلاثه ونصف بالماء لكن مشاهدينا ما
هي اكبر منتجات الغذائيه التي دافعت
اسعارها في فتره الاثني عشر شهرا المنتهيه
في نوفمبر رايت الاحصاء اجابت بان اسعار
اللحوم والدجاج الاكبر في الارتفاع حيث
زادت اسعارها عن العام الماضي اكثر من
اربعه ونصف % لنتجه الان الى اسعار
السيارات نشاهد انها ارتفعت عن العام
الماضي بنسبه تقترب من 5% اما اسعار وجبات
في المطاعم والفنادق فارتفعت بنسبه تقترب
من سبعه في المئه خلال عام او خلال عام
واحد كان نافث ايضا مشاهدينا ان هيئه
الاحصاء ذكرت ان تكاليف استخدام العماله
المنزليه ان خافضت عن العمل الماضي بنسبه
تجاوزت اربعه ونصف بالمائه وختاما دعونا
نشاهد ارتفاع تضخم الشهري في هذا العام في
يناير نشاهد ان الارتفاع كان بنسبه واحد
وعشرين في المئه قفز في ابريل الى اثنين
وثلاثه عشر في المئه ثم في اغسطس زادت
نسبه التضخم الى ثلاثه في المئه واخيرا في
نوفمبر تباطئ هذا تضخم وصل الى اثنين
وتسعه اعشاب في المياه
وبحسب الميزانيه السعوديه الاخيره من
المتوقع ان يبلغ معدل التضخم العام 20 22
16% ليكون من بين الادنى عالميا
الثقافه والتعليم الاستراتيجيات التنميه
القدرات الثقافيه بالشراكه مع عدد من
الجهه الاخرى بهدف ربط مخرجات التعليم
باحتياجات سوق العمل في القطاع الثقافي
وستعملها للاستراتيجيه الادراج الثقافه
والفنون في كافه مراحل التعليم والتدريب
التقني والمهني تسال استراتيجيه للتحقيق
اول مستهدفاتتها بحلول 2016 منها ان تقدم
اكثر من نصف مدارس التعليم العام انشطه
صيفيه ثقافيه وان يختار اكثر من خمسه في
المئه من خارج التعليم العام التخصص
والعمل في مجالات الثقافه اضافه الى تخريج
اكثر من 20,000 متخصص في مجالات الثقافه
والوصول الى 120 مؤسسه تدريبيه في مجالات
الثقافه
انضم الى هنا في استديوهاتنا من الرياض
نهى قطان وكيل وزاره الثقافه للشركات
الوطنيه والتطوير اهلا وسهلا استاذ عماد
مبروك عليكم اول من اطلاق الاستراتيجيه
تعرفين عليها بشكل اكبر ما هي هذه
الاستراتيجيه شكرا
من بعد ما انتهينا من الوضع الوطنيه
للثقافه اللي شاهدنا فيها عوامل التمكين
المطلوبه لتطوير القطاع الثقافي لكامل
اهمها تعزيز التطوير تعليمي والتدريبي
لهذه القطاعات اللي همم نحتاج نشوفها على
مستوى التخصص
وبدانا من هذه الرحله لوضع هذه
الاستراتيجيه بالشراكه زي ما اتفقت معها
وزاره التعليم وزاره الموارد البشريه
المؤسسه العامه للتدريب التقني والمهني
وايضا مع كافه الجامعات اللي موجوده في
المملكه
يعني الصلب لكن همم ممكن احنا ما نطلقها
اليوم لكن فعلا بدا العمل عليها من العمل
ماضي فكان في عندنا تجارب اوليه بداناها
سواء عن بعض المشاريع التجريبيه اللي
اطلقناها ولا حتى بعض الانجازات الحقيقيه
ايجابيه عن التعليم الثقافه والفنون في
المملكه وتخريج عدد من المتخصصين
والمهنيين في القطاعات الثقافي بالمملكه
واخيرا وظائف ومهن همم مستدامه في القطاع
الثقافي بشكل
وجلساتكم مع وزاره التعليم وصول هذه
لاطلاق
20 20 علاقتنا شراكه سواء مع وزاره
التعليم او المؤسسه العامه للتدريب التقني
والمهني وكانت هذه حجر الاساس اللي وضعناه
وبدانا منه بشكل مشترك
فبدانا العمل على تطويرها والدراسه بشكل
مشترك بينه وبينهم واستمر هذا العمل على
مدار العام الماضيين واي تفيد المرحله
القادمه يعتبر تكامل وتضافر الجهود من هذه
الجهات مجتمعه عشان ان شاء الله نحققه
بدايه السنه
بدايه السنه الدراسيه ان شاء الله نشوف
يعني دخولها على المناهج وعلى التعليم
العام بشكل عام لكن ايضا بالتزامن احنا
ارادي بدانا اطلاق بعض المراحل التعليميه
الاخرى سواء الاكاديميه المتخصصه ولا
المعاهد التدريبيه الخاصه بالتعاون مع
المؤسسه العامه لتدريب التقني والمهني ولا
حتى بعض حاضنات الفنون والاخمات الفنيه
وغيرها من مجالات اللي اطلقناها سابقات
في مناهج الطلاب والتعليم الان بعد هذه
الاستراتيجيه مع بدايه السنه في اي
المراحل
طبعا ثقافه والفنون هي موجوده في مناهج
التعليميه من الاساس احنا اليوم جهودنا
تعزز هذا
اليوم اعتقد الوضع مختلف ومتغيره ومتطور
مش الاضافات الجديده
[موسيقى]
الوزاره
الوطنيه وبالتالي هذه الاستراتيجيه راح
تشمل وتغطي كافه هذه المناهج او هذه
المجالات الثقافيه
التعليم على وضع الاطار الوطني لتعليم
الثقافه والفنون واللي هيحدد اليه الادراك
وشكل ادراج هذا سواء في المناهج او بشكل
صفي وايضا الادراج بشكل مرحله
كين اهم اعطائهم وتزويدهم همم يمكن همم
المهارات المطلوبه وطبيعه الخلفيه
في في مدارس في في قطاعات معينه
عدد من المدارس تم منحها بعض الالات وبعض
المناهج والتدريب المعلمينها اطلقنا
الاسبوع الماضي تدريب لمعلمي او المسرح
المدرسي والمعلمين القائمين عليه ايضا في
رياض الاطفال بدا العمل على تدريب بعض
معلمين ومعلمات عفوا رياض الاطفال في هذا
المجال
كيف تكون المنهجيه في التعليم يعني هل
ستكون
جميع اختياريه ستبدا بمراحل معينه حتى
نفهم الصوره
المواد والمجال الثقافي تختلف طريقه
ادراجها ووو جزء منها راح يكون ضمن مواد
اوردي موجوده وضمن وجزء منها راح يكون في
مواد اضافيه مستقله فتختلف تختلف ايضا
بحسب طبيعه الفئه العمريه المستهدفه لكل
واحده من هذه المجالات سيكون يمكن بشكل
اوليه مختلفه
يمكن نخصص لها مساحه اكبر يمكن في نشرتنا
لاحقه انا اشكرك شكرا جزيلا ويبارك لكم
مره ثانيه يعني اطلاق هذه الاستراتيجيه
وكل التوفيق لكم دائم شكرا لك
وزاره الثقافه للشركات الوطنيه
اكدت رئيسه هيئه حقوق الانسان السعوديه هل
توجد فيها انها حقوق الانسان مسؤوليته كل
الجهات وليست حكرا على جهه معينه مشيره
الى ان الحوار والتبادل الخبرات يحققان
الاهداف المرجوه
الاساسي هو ايصال رساله انا حقوق الانسان
دور منى به كل الجهات
الحقيقه يعني احنا في الهيئه نقوم ربما
بدور تنسيقي تكامل مع الجهاز همم نعزز
ادوار الجهات الاخرى ولكن الدور الاساسي
هو دور الجهاد فمن خلال هذه الاحداث
والمناسبات نريد ان نحدث هذا النوع من
الزخم حول موضوع حقوق الانسان ولتاكيد على
ان حقوق الانسان مسؤوليه الجميع على كل
الاصعده
في السعوديه ايضا على نت الهيئه العامه
للاحصاء عن ارتفاع حجم المسطحات الخضراء
والحدائق بنسبه 9% عام 2021 مقارنه عام
2020 تقرير لاحصاء كشف ايضا بان اجماليه
محطات معالجه المياه المعاد استخدامها
ارتفع بالنسبه تتجاوز 66% في العام الماضي
لمسجلت منطقه الرياض اعلى عدد لمحطه
المعالجه بواقعي 26 محطه
كشف المركز الوطني للارصاد في السعوديه ان
الامطار التي هطلت على مدينه جده في
الرابع والعشرين من الشهر الماضي تعد
ظاهره جويه ترقى الى المستوى الحاله
المتطرفه قياسا بكميات الامطار والعامل
الزمنيه لها واكد المركز ايضا انه يعمل
على دراسه هذه الخاله ومقارنتها بضواهر
الجويه اثرت على مناطق مختلفه في الاعوام
الماضيه مبينا بان السعوديه ليست بمن انا
عن الظواهر الجويه المتطرفه
قسم السدود الاحترازيه شرق مدينه جده في
غرب السعوديه بدء مخاطر السيول على احياء
المدينه
الدخول كميات كبيره من المياه خلال
الحالات المطريه
في منطقه مكه المكرمه على الصيانه
المستمره الابواب السدود ومجسم السجود
وازاله الطمي من حوض السدود وازاله الجميع
التي تعيق
من جد ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه سلطان
السلامي سلطان مرحبا بك كيف عملت بالفعل
هذه السدود
الحمايه جده في وقت يقول في البعض والكثير
بان لم تفلح طبعا في اداره مخاطر السيول
اللي وصلت الاماكن كثيره فيه
اهلا اهلا
العربيه اريد ان اريدكم يعني بعض المشاهد
لاحد السدود التي عملت عليها الجهات
الحكوميه هنا في محافظه جده وهي عددها 14
سد ناقف الان في في حي الحرازات وتحديدا
الشرق محافظه جده وهذا احد السدود كما
تشاهدون الان بعد ان هطلت الامطار برقم او
بمسوب قياسي يسجله سجلتها محافظه جده وصول
ال187 ملم من المياه نشاهد الان هذا السد
الذي يعتبر او قارب على الانتهاء من تصريف
المياه عبر ثلاثه مجاري رئيسيه في جده ومن
ثم وصولا الى البحر نتحدث وتستغرق عمليات
تصريف المياه داخل السدود جدا 14 المنتشره
في الشرق وجنوب محافظه جده 15 يوم فقط عبر
انابيب يتم همم تخرج المياه من هذه السدود
وصول الى مجاري المياه الثلاثه عبر هذه هي
الاوديه في شرق جده تحديدا ومن ثم الى
مجاري المياه وصولا الى البحر الاحمر
اليوم هنالك استعدادات كبيره تعمل عليها
الوزارات المشاركه في مواسم الامطار من
خلال تنظيف هذه المجاري بعد تفريغها من
المياه يتم تنظيف المداخل الخاصه لها
والمجاري لها داخل الاوديه من الشوائب او
حتى المخلفات اليوم هذه السدود 14 ساهمت
بشكل كبير جدا بعد ان سجلت جده رقم قياسي
في منسوب المياه وصول
ال187
مليمتر ساهمت بشكل كبير نشاهد انه بعد هذا
هذه المنطقه هنالك احياء سكنيه وتحديد
الحي الحرازات ومن ثم حي الصواعد وصول الى
الخط السريع عبر مناطق واحياء مختلفه
ساهمت بشكل كبير لم نشاهد هنالك اضرار
كبيره جدا لحقت المنازل هو السيارات او
حتى المركبات في هذه المناطق لكن فيما
يتعلق بجران المياه يتم بكل انسيابيه تخرج
من هذه السدود قمنا بجوله عبر كذا همم سد
في هذه المنطقه شهاده ان هي تم تفريغها
بالكامل عبر هذه الانابيب وهذه المجاريه
الخاصه
بالسيول الامطار واجرين السيول بشكل عام
اليوم يعني هذه السدود خصه الاستيعاب اكثر
من
243 ملم من المياه وهذه الحاله المطريه
وهذا الرقم يعني لا ياتي الا بعد سنوات
طويله جدا بحسب الحاله الجويه لكن جد
اليوم سجلت 187 مللي تعاملت مع هذه الصدو-
هذه السدود بشكل ممتاز وجيد اريد ان اؤكد
على اللقطه مهمه جدا وشاهد امام الكاميرا
الان هذا المجرى يتم دخول المياه وصولا من
المناطق الشرقيه المرتفعه وهذه الجبال في
هذه المنطقه وصول الى هذه المجر والدخول
عبر انابيب كبيره جدا وضخمه ومن ثم تمر
عبر هذه المجال التي ظهرناها ظهرناها قبل
قليل الوصول الى مجال المياه الثلاثه
الرئيسيه الى همم الى البحر بشكل سهل جدا
بعيدا عن المواطنين وبعيدا عن حتى
المركبات والمناطق السكنيه التي تقع
بالقرب من هذه المنطقه اليوم فيما يتعلق
بالجهود التي تعمل نشاهد صباح اليوم يظهر
هنالك جهات رقابيه حكوميه التقينا بها
التقينا بهم اليوم نوه بانه هنالك عمليات
تنظيف مستمره والتاكد من فعاليات هذه
السدود والصيانتها بشكل دوري ومستمر نعم
خالد
السدود تتركز في منطقه واحده ولا في مناطق
اخرى هل تختلف المساله من مكان الى اخر
ايضا
تتركز هذه المناطق
بالعموم في منطقه الشرق محافظه جده وتندم
في حي الحرازات وحي السامر ومنطقه ابراج
الرغامه وغيره من الحاله التي تقع على
الجهه الشرقيه في محافظه جده التي تكون
اكثر تضررا بحكم الحالات المطريه السابقه
في جدله تتحدث عن 2011 و2012 التي شهدت
جده امطار غزيره جدا كانت اكثر المناطق
تضررا هي مناطق شرق محافظه جده 14 سد بهذا
الشكل وبهذا التصميم ينتشرون على شريط
طويل جدا في مناطق مختلفه للتعامل مع
منسوب المياه الكبيره او جريان السيوله
التي تاتي في هذه المنطقه بحسب الحاله
الجويه لذلك نشاهد سدود مصممه مصممه بشكل
همم دقيق جدا تتعامل مع منسوب مياه عاليه
يتم تصريفها بشكل ذكي مده الاستيعاب
للمياه المنطقه
الشرقيه اللي كانت متضرره في فتره لكن ما
زالت ايضا هذه المناطق ايضا تضررت في
الامطار الاخيره
نعم كلام تتدرب بشكل كبير
كما السابق نظرا لوجود
هذه بنسبه كبيره جدا لمياه الامطار في وقت
سابقا كانت نشاهد يعني مشاهد ماساويه
كبيره في هذه المنطقه لكن بعد تفعيل هذه
السدود منذ سنوات سابقه يعني ردعت بشكل
كبير جدا هذه المياه لدى كل مشاهد انه
واحنا واحنا في طريقه للدخولنا الى هذه
المنطقه نشاهد البيوت لم تتضرر المناطق او
الاستراحات الخاصه في هذه المنطقه لم
تلحقها او لم يلحقها ضرر كبير جدا في هذه
المنطقه نظره لوجود هذه السدود التي تم
وضعها وفقا خرائط ووفق مساحات محدده ووفق
اوديه كبيره او متوسطه الحجم لذلك تم وضع
هذه التعامل مع هذه الحالات المطريه
المختلفه التي تشهده جدا
كشفت هيئه الاتصالات والفضاء والتقنيه
السعوديه عن امكانيه ربط 500 مليون جهاز
انترنت الاشعه عبر نشر شبكه تقنيه ان بي
الاوتي عبر اكثر من 20,000 برج بالنسبه
للتغطيه تجاوزت 95% من المناطق الحضريه
الهيئه واوضحت انها عملت على تحفيز
الاستثمار في القطاع من خلال بنيه تحتيه
متينه تساهم في تغطيه اكثر من ثلاثه
ملايين و600,000 منزل بالالياف الضوئيه
الرابعه ايضا بعد الفاصل
العربيه تتجول في مسقط وترافق شابا عمانيا
يطمح لتوفيق التراث الغذائي والماكولات
العمانيه
بعثه الاتحاد الاوروبي والسفير الامريكي
في اليمن يدعواني لتجنب التصعيد واعاده
تثبيت الهدى
احصائيه سعوديه تكشف ارتفاع ايجارات الشقق
بنسبه تقترب من 16 في المئه الشهر الماضي
السعوديه تطلق استراتيجيه تنميه القدرات
الثقافيه لربط مخرجات التعليم باحتياجات
سوق العمل
مدينه جده تستعد لاحتضان اول بنالي للفنون
الاسلاميه في العالم تحت شعار اول بيت
اهلا بكم رئيس قسم الجراحه الاطفال
بمستشفى الملك عبد الله التخصصي للاطفال
بوزاره الحرس الوطني الدكتور محمد
المنشاوي للعربيه بانه تم اجراء جزء من
الفحوصات الحيويه الاوليه للتوام السيامي
النيجيري حسين وحسنه مؤكدا بان النتائج
كانت ايجابيه وان الفريق الطبي سيبوت في
قرار اجراء العمليه بعد اكتمال هذه
الفحوصات مشيرا في الوقت ذاته الى ان
الفريق اجرى عمليات فصل مشابهه للتوام
السيامي الحالي وكانت توام من نيجيري وصل
الاسبوع الماضي الى الرياض بامر من العاهل
السعوديه الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز من
اجل دراسه حالتهما والنظر في امكانيه
اجراء عمليه فصلهم
الحمد لله كما ترى حسنه وحسينا يعني وضعهم
الحمد لله مستقر همم
العلامات الملحويه ممتازه
تم عمل بعض الفحوصات المبدئيه السوائل
الفحص السريريه او فحوصات الدم وهمم بعض
الفحوصات الاشعاعيه ان شاء الله في هذا
الاسبوع
تقريبا الاسبوع القادم نكتمل الفحوصات بعد
اكتمال الفحوصات باذن الله يجتمع الفريق
المعالج همم ويناقش امكانيه الفصل تستعد
مدينه جده غربيه السعوديه لاحتضانها اول
بنالي للفنون الاسلاميه في العالم من
المقرر ان يستمر ثلاثه اشهر خلال الفتره
من الثالث والعشرين من يناير الى الثالث
23 من ابريل الى 2023
سيقام المعرض تحت شعار اول بيت في صاله
الحجاج الغربيه بمطار الملك عبد العزيز
الدولي لما لها من اهميه خاصه كونها اول
بوابه تستقبل الملايين من الحجاج وسيضم
اعمالا فنيه معاصره لفنانين تتكامل
اعمالهم مع قطاع اثريه تاريخيه تعرض
للجمهور لاول مره تما استعرتها من مؤسسات
المحليه واقليميه ودوليه متخصصه في مجال
الفنون الاسلاميه
بهدفه رفع مستوى جوده الحياه والتعرف على
الوجهات والمواقع الاثريه والطبيعيه في
اثراء التجربه السياحيه وتعظيم الفوائد
الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه في السعوديه غادر
الفهد
درب موسيقى الواقع غربي الرياض مسار تم
عمله من قبل جمعيه درب يهدف الى تطوير
ثقافه المشي والهايكنج حسب له طوله هذا
المسار حوالي عاشت كيلومترات ذهابا وايابا
يبدا بمنطقه ترابيه ويمتد الى منطقه
الصخور البركانيه والدوائر الحجريه التي
يبلغ عمرها الاف السنين الان هالحين خمس
مسرات انتهينا منها المخطط حل يعني خلال
الشهر هذا ان شاء الله هنخلص كمان اربع
مسارات فهيكون خلالها السنه هذه تسع
مسارات تنتهينا منها السنه الجايه ان شاء
الله خطتنا هيكون فيها حوالي 40 مسار خلال
خمس سنين احنا ناويين ندبل المسارات كل
سنه يعني حلمنا ان نوصل الى الف مساء خلال
خمس سنين ينتهي المسار بالوصول الى جبل
صغير
يضم واحده من اضخم الوجهات الصخاريه
المغطاه بفنون النحت الصخري تعود ثمانيه
الاف سنه وتفرد باشكال نادره لانواع
الحيوانات التي كانت تعيش في تلك المنطقه
هذه اللي خلف بنات تتكون من 210 رسم صخري
وهي تعتبر من اكبر الواجهات في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه طبعا عندنا مثل ما ذكرنا
له 15 واجهه صخريه في الموقع شرقيه وغربيه
وجنوبيه وشماليه
وعمره اقدم رسم موجود في هذه المنطقه همم
يعود الى زمن ما يقارب 6000 سنه قبل
الميلاد يعني ما يقارب ثمانيه الاف سنه من
العراق
وتهيئته ليكون مسارا واضحا يسهل للجميع
ارتياده والمشي فيه وذلك لجلب الانتباه
لمنطقه سنيكره والتعرف على المزيد من
المعالم السياحيه والتاريخيه
ممارس الهايكنج يجمع بين الرياضه والتعايش
مع الطبيعه في واحد من الرياضات التي باتت
منتشره على نطاق واسعا في السعوديه بين
مختلف الفئات العمريه ويعدها البعض فرصه
لتعريف بالمعالم السياحيه
والاثريه والتضاريس المتنوعه في البلاد
غدا الفهد العربيه الرياض
يه
اكثر من 120 اكله بحسب الباحثين هذا شجع
الباحث العمراني لتاسيس مشروع ثقافي
لتوفيق هذه الاكلات العمانيه وبعد جوله
طويله قام بها على ولايات السلطنه والتي
التقى خلالها بالكثير من المختصين
والسيدات وكبار السن توفيق المطبخ العماني
ولكن بطريقه فنيه وابداعيه عبد الرحمن
العصيميته
[موسيقى]
ياتي هذا الشاب العماني كل يوم الى مكتبه
في منطقه بوشر بالعاصمه العمانيه مسقط
منهمك لساعات طويله في انجاز مشروع الذي
يعتبره حلما لطالما اراد تحقيقه خليل
الحسيني شاب عماني يطمح الى توثيق التراث
الغذائي والماكولات العمانيه بطريقه فنيه
وابداعيه
[موسيقى]
مشروع الفنون تحتها عده برامج نحن جالسين
نشتغل عليها اول برنامج اللي هو ان نحن
نعمل
مقاييس معايير للماكولات العمانيه بحيث ان
احنا ننتج كتاب من بعد الكتاب في برامج
كثيره ما نذكرها الحين لان شغالين فيها
على اساس فكره المشروع ما ما احد ياخذها
خليل تجول في الكثير من المدن العمانيه
لتوفيق الاكلات مستفيدا من معلومات
الجمعيات المراه العمانيه في كل ولايه الى
جانب كبار السن حتى تمكن من توثيق اكثر من
90 اكله حتى الان
[موسيقى]
في عمان وصورنا اغلب الماكولات العمانيه
طبعا الماكولات
120 اكله عمانيه نحنا صورنا الماكولات
النادره
همم
الناس ما تعرفك
[تصفيق]
يهدف الحسيني من خلال هذا المشروع الى
ترسيخ قيمه المروث الغذائيه العمانيه
وتشجيع الباحثين للاستثمار في مجالات
الطهي في الحقيقه احنا عندنا يعني اهداف
كثيره في المشروع
الهدف الاساسي ان احنا نكون عندنا محتوى
في الماكولات فنون طهي العماني نفس الشيء
امام
المجتمعولاتنا قبل ان نحن همم نسوقها
للخارج همم يكون عندنا اعتزاز همم
الناس بثقافه همم فنون الطهي الاعماني
بحيث ان احنا همم
ننسخ في ال- همم في العالم ان احنا عندنا
اكل مميز ممكن الناس تجيء قريبا سيقوم
خليل الحسيني باصدار كتاب لتصليط الضوء
على ذكر الموارد الاساسيه في طبخ
الماكولات في السلطه كزراعه الثوم والبصل
وصناعه ماء الورد والفل
عبد الرحمن العصيمي من مسقط العربيه
[موسيقى]
كان العرب القدماء يعرفون موعد مربعانيه
الشتاء عن طريق كسر غصون الشجره
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
فهمنا الاولين الله يرحمهم
كانوا اذا كسروا غصن اشترى ولا وجدوا فيه
ماء وذاقه وهدب الاثل وجدوا ولا حموضه
خفيفه قال وترى مربعانيه الشتاء دخلت واذا
افرزه الصدره والطلحه ماده حمراء او صفراء
قالوا ترى مربعانيه البيض دخلت والعرب
القدماء يقولون اذا حاضت السدره فهذا امار
على شده الحر ففي مربعانيه الشتاء يتوقف
الماء عن الجريان في غصون الاشجار فتقص
استخدام للعصي او البناء او الاواني
المنزليه وقمه البؤشي ان تبكيك ذاكره
بمنزل كنت دوما فيه
تبتسم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
والعرب القدماء لهم طرق شتى في معرفه
الفصول والواسم مختلفه باختلاف الثقافات
والبيئه المحيطه بهم فالزراع على السلوك
الزراعي والباديه على السلوك الحشري وعلى
تحركات الرياح وتخلفات السحب واهل البحر
على الرؤيه العيانيه لذات النجم ومشاعر
الشمس وقالوا تتوب على الهواء قلت لا لا
تتوب الشمس اما اطلع الشرك
الظلام اشتعاله بين البروق وبين مبسم هيا
فرق
[موسيقى]
العنوي
الاتحاد الاوروبي
اعضاء في مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي للعربيه
يعربون
احصائيه سعوديه تكشف ارتفاع الجارات الشقق
بنسبه تقتربه من 16 في المئه الشهر الماضي
جده تستضيف او تحتضنوا اولا بنال للفنون
الاسلاميه في العالم تحت شعار اول بيت
والعربيه تتجول في مسقط
وترافق التراث الغذائي والماكولات
العمانيه
[موسيقى]